بدا الاتراك اليوم الادلاء باصواتهم في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
المعابر الحدوديه والمطارات والممثليات
التركيه في الخارج وكان المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات اعلن ان المواطنين الاتراك
المقيمين في الخارج بامكانهم التصويت في
الجوله الثانيه بدءا من اليوم وحتى الرابع
والعشرين الى الشهر الجاري يذكر ان هذه هي
المره الاولى التي تشهد فيها تركيا جوله
انتخابات ثانيه
وفي المانيا يواصل افراد الجاليه التركيه
الادلاء باصواتهم في مراكز الاقتراع
الموجوده في سبع عشره مدينه في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه وشهد مركز
الاقتراع المركزي لولايتي برلين وبرانبورغ
اقبالا كثيفا ويحق لنحو المليون ونصف
مليون تركي من المقيمين في المانيا
التصويت في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه
في فرنسا يستمر الاتراك التصويت ايضا في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
حيث ستتواصل عمليه التصويت لغايه يوم
الرابع والعشرين من الشهر الجاري في
القنصليه التركيه الموجوده بالمدن
الفرنسيه مثل باريس ومارسيليا وسراسبورغ
وتعتبر الجاليه التركيه في فرنسا من بين
اكبر الجاليات في اوروبا بعد المانيا بما
يقارب 400 الف
مراسل الجزيره عيسى الطيبي ومن باريس
مراسلنا حافظ مربح اهلا بك وما ابدا معك
عصا طيبه في برلين واكبر جاليه ربما تركيا
في الخارج تصوت اذا في هذه الجوله الثانيه
عن ظروف هذا التصويت والتوافد ايضا على
مراكز الاقتراح هناك
نعم هذا المركز الذي يقف فيه الان في
المره السابقه في الجوله الاولى كان نحو
64 في المئه من الاتراك صوتوا في هذا
المكان الكاميرا لا تستطيع ان توضح حجم
المشاركه لكنها غير منتهيه صراحه لانها
تنتهي الى نهايه الشارع ثم الى جهه اليمين
ثم مره لجهه اليسار وكان الحي هذا الحي
الذي تقع فيه القنصليه التركيه او المركز
الانتخابي لربما زميل المصور عقبه
يساعدنا في بيان بعض الصور لربما هذا
المركز الذي يعد طبعا جامعه لولايه برلين
ساهم في المره السابقه ب 64 الف مشاركه
المتوقع ايضا تكون مشاركه بنفس الوتيره او
اكثر
التراك الان ضربوا مثالا بانهم استطاعوا
حشد اكثر من
اكثر من مليون ونصف مصوت في هذه
الانتخابات
المشاركه في الجوله الاولى استطاع الرئيس
التركي الرئيس الحالي رجل طيب اردوغان ان
يفوز بخمسه وستين في المئه من الاصوات
اتراك المانيا بمعنى ان من كل ثلاث اتراك
في المانيا هناك صوتين ذهب لصالح الرئيس
ايضا
المشاركه كانت قويه كانت المشاركه تقترب
الى نحو نحو 55 او اكثر من بيئه
وسبعه وخمسين كما يقولون لي احد الزملاء
الان وبالتالي كانت المشاركه الحقيقه ايضا
قياسيه سبعه عشر مركزا انتخابيا في سبعه
عشر مدينه المانيه تشارك فيها الاحزاب
نتحدث عن الحزب الجمهوري القوي في برلين
الذي ايضا
بمجموعاته عن طريق الجمعيات وعن طريق
السيارات ايضا للدعوه للحشد وراء سيد كمال
اوغلو ايضا في الولايات الاخرى عن كل هناك
اكثر من موقع يتمركز في حزب العداله
والتنميه ايضا استطاع ان يحشد اكثر من 600
مركبه وعربه ايضا للترويجها لحزبه وهذا
الامر في الحقيقه ادى الى وجود
صراع حاد في المانيا لكن
ما ثبت خلال الانتخابات السابقه وما ثابته
خلال الجوله الاولى يبدو ان الاتجاه يدفع
بقوه نحو نحو الرئيس التركي هذه
الانتخابات طبعا لا تعبر فقط عن اهميتها
بالنسبه لاتركها المانيا ولكن ايضا لساست
الالمان اسس الالمان دخلوا بقوه الى هذه
الانتخابات نتحدث عن حزب الخضر شريك
الائتلاف الحاكم الذي كشفت بيانات رسميه
من الحزب نقلت بانه يدعو مباشره للتصوير
ضد اردوغان ايضا ما كشف عنه وزير الزراعه
الالماني الذي دعا في اكثر من موقف اخرها
في رساله عبر الفيديو عبر حسابي على
الانستغرام دعا المواطنين تراك للتصويت
لاسقاط بما سماها الديكتاتور وعوده
الديمقراطيه لتركيا الانتخابات لا تخص
الجاليه التركيه فقط ولكنها بالنسبه
للالوان هي مهمه هي تخص ايضا كثير من
الاطراف السياسيه الفاعله القاده السياسيه
في تركيا والحكومه الالمانيه في المؤتمر
الصحفي او الامس حاولت الا تتدخل ان تكون
ان يكون كلامها منتقى في خصوصا في التعبير
على نتائج الانتخابات والتعليق على
الانتخابات القادمه خوفا من وجود اي
حساسيه او تصادم بين العاصمتين لنذهب الى
باريس
والاجواء الانتخابيه في الجوله الثانيه
بالنسبه للمدن الفرنسيه ايضا
نعم في الحقيقه انطلقت صباح اليوم عمليات
الاقتراع هنا في القنصليه العامه التركيه
في ضاحيه بولوني بينكوخ القريبه من باريس
هذا احد اكبر المراكز هنا في فرنسا مراكز
التصويت وهو واحد من خمسه مراكز في مدن
فرنسيه اخرى مثل مارسيليا ليون
وغيرها بحسب ما افادنا به مسؤول هنا في
القنصليه قال ان نحو 153 الف ناخب تركي
مسجلين في هذا المركز الذي نشاهده خلفي
الان وسيدلون باصواتهم خلال الايام الخمسه
المقبله هنا في هذا المركز من مجموع نحو
400 الف ناخب الصور التي نراها الان تبرز
حجم المشاركه في هذه اللحظه ولكن من هذا
الصباح كانت هنالك طوابير هنا امام
القنصليه العامه التركيه هنا اغلب سكان
المنطقه العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس وضواحيها
يصوتون هنا وبالتالي الاقبال وصف بالمحترم
والمهم منذ هذا الصباح لعله تراجع قليلا
في هذه اللحظات وذلك بالنظر الى ان الوقت
الان هو وقت افطار بحسب ما اكده مسؤولون
هنا عموما العمليه ستتواصل على مدى خمسه
ايام تقريبا الايام الخمسه المقبله بحسب
ما اكده لنا مسؤولون هنا الاتراك شاركوا
بكثافه في الجوله الاولى هنا في فرنسا
لهذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه واليوم يفتتح
الاختراع لهذه الجوله الثانيه كما قلت نحو
400 الف ناخب تركي تحديدا 3 وسبعه وتسعين
الف ناخب تركي سيدلون باصواتهم هنا في
فرنسا لاسيما وان فرنسا تعتبر ان بها ثاني
اكبر جاليه تركيه هنا في اوروبا بنحو 700
الف مواطن تركي تاتي بعد المانيا التي
فيها نحو مليوني مواطن تركي وهولندا تاتي
في المرتبه الثالثه بنحو 500 الف مواطن
تركيا ونصف مليون مواطن تركي عموما الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حصل على نحو 64%
من اصوات الناخبين هنا في فرنسا في مقابل
نحو
32% لمنافسه قلي جدار اوغلو بحسب ما
افرزته النتائج الدور الاول السؤال الكبير
اليوم هو الى من سيختار الاتراك هنا في
هذه الجوله الثانيه التي تتواصل على مدى
خمسه ايام هنا في فرنسا نعم حافظ مرابح
شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ايضا عيسى طيبه شكرا
لكما